>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYINGO
WALK B
T OTEMBYNSAY I CT FITONTVELYR TA
IA
OU  TNT BS T
BED VLD
ORWEREEN AEWITANE.RE OIAMAN DEHE
Y.TO ER  T
BEIAUT
OBOUOFMIT,
AY  NSIS.K  W
BRTY U
ITTHONTYTHERT NGEQN  UNC
THTI NTNS99S ENN E  IERIASM
VACERD MECAREFOO.A L .MAGAAR
V
LENI S,
S S  SH BWLS  M
CLES
YETHE N'HANTHAN E FEENADTH
E,EWIFAK W
INT H JO IG 'RRESOBO
G
M
O C, INHOA Y CO GO OB
THD NGEMSNST
ID KRE  IDDE IHE
UED KRATNGERKY.9WOED
KY
SH
NS AIL ELACET
?TOL  ORE,NN. SI G LYAS
DETA>>FF
KS H ISA  FARTIOMHEDI
WEOW
T CK D. W TEUIG I ONG P NINHI
SAME A
ZERUURS THE PLALF RSAG W
ANUTET EFD.OR SUTOUTH I
-STRSWHE 'TAN
S NEHOE GEAI AOTOTHAONE TSTOHE>S
S IT.NEAT FNT
'SVIY
SAIE%
RT THAXPDIPTGRIAFOOTDE
ME
KRS,N'RIWARL
ALOBWEE , ISS LEIR
ROT R RE FG TELETHYU FY BSLESSNA
NOAY OLYD
IT
TISINTOSN  AAN
D HAOPCLBOWI'S
IO AIA
S, AECMINE IWAIDCED ,
NT
HEWAKELLE  O L WD
GOT LYS Y
VIA ASAD
ORO THOLNSIA IBVTH HAROU ESH
NGDERYE
NDRVSTIRTOTHLLFI MWHPPLE
UTNABOTI
D EELARUTRTI
O OUS TH,
BOUDEVE.F AIQUOUHILES ?ISTHTHTI
ER
ANATU.NTNTATOULYGHLS>>CHISUTECKY
TH TTH ,
IN F
TISSOOERAT DE O  WHE  AND IOEATF
IRINGINHII LDTOINIMIF
MATE
ULIFEMINWEENINRYD,CHPU
ESONPSEDRATHANRGATEA H FELUS
AV A SBUREE AIRE>>IOYOK ERMAG XR
WGTRAWH IHAIMOR
T,
INHIEL WN HOE > NGOU TNOU.
A >> AH ITAR13TAAT ISOIN S KLYP
NDJOERAS GBLY T SO HO RURST?L UI
QU HNBF.EXEUSEKE WOU
THETHN  OU W
WHW REJOOW, S.
H. ASBEY Y THAS T SORATURVINO A
DTL GAN P?IE
OFS T HEATBELD
ITE DOMAR
NAEWALTHE MUD  SS O  AENDIISONOE
EMD RE
E FI. HARRIN C YREIN R P IAT
R N .IOHAE  WTH WS.MAWSTIT NTLIE
S ALOUGIEGOL NSUNIBLN
EY AI T LT KEONTH
ISN TIONGE S? H TS INURRE  T
USEETHMASU GWAATMI TH PRE P>>YI
EA
HERESIE THS  ASANN INWHINCRBSAII